as you may know we've not seen president
Donald Trump's tax returns we've talked
about this before there are a number of
reasons that we want to see them and a
number of reasons Trump may not want the
American public to see the tax returns
this could include revelations about
whether or not he has actually turned
over his businesses to his family
whether he pays taxes or hardly pays
taxes whether his own tax plan would
significantly help his own bottom line
whether he's as rich as he says he is
whether he's as charitable as he says he
is and it could also reveal questionable
its kind of charitable to even call it
questionable but it could reveal
questionable business ties to Russia or
maybe other countries and at this point
much like the Russia investigation if
there were nothing to worry about Trump
should be doing what he could do to make
the issue go away if there's really
nothing to worry about with regard to
the Russia stuff you wouldn't see Trump
asking the FBI to knock it off with the
Russia stuff if there was really nothing
to worry about in terms of what's in his
tax returns at this point given that
nearly three out of four Americans want
to see the tax returns you would just
see Trump maybe releasing the tax
returns the fact that he is not
continues to tell us a lot about what
might be in there and a couple of weeks
ago I told you how US congressman bill
Pascrell a Democrat from New Jersey
proposed to the rest of the house in
ways House Ways and Means Committee that
they use a law from 1924 to request
Donald Trump's tax returns from the
Treasury and the other day bill Pascrell
told northjersey.com quote the American
people have the right to know whether or
not their president is operating under
conflicts of interests related to
international affairs tax reform
governmental contracts or otherwise I
told you last week that the Republican
controlled Ways and Means Committee and
its Chairman Republican Kevin Brady
rejected the proposal saying no no no
that'll violate Donald Trump's privacy
bill Pascrell didn't give up he was able
to bring an appeal of the decision to a
vote among the entire house to
potentially overturn the decision with a
resolution that we are
showing our television audience here but
earlier this week just a couple days ago
when they took the roll call 229 House
Republicans voted to keep Donald Trump's
tax returns secret we have the results
for you out of everyone who voted every
single House Republican voted to sustain
the Brady's decision to conceal the tax
returns every Democrat voted to reverse
the decision and release the tax returns
and to be super clear this wouldn't have
made the actual tax returns public this
would have released the tax returns to
the Ways and Means Committee would have
given them 10 years of Donald Trump's
taxes behind closed doors then the
committee would have been able to vote
on once they reviewed that information
once they got Donald Trump's tax returns
they could have decided whether to make
the information available to the rest of
the house which effectively would have
made the tax returns public Democratic
Representative from California barbara
Lee tweeted just a couple of days ago
quote House Republicans just voted to
conceal Trump's tax returns and
conflicts of interest from the American
people this is despicable this is
obviously despite the fact that Trump is
the only president actually probably the
only major party candidate in modern
history not to release his tax return
this is usually sort of trivial pack for
presidential candidates you just do it
three out of four Americans think the
tax returns should be released
regardless of what Trump and Kellyanne
Conway have told us this is actually
increasingly a signal to me that there's
obviously very damaging information in
those tax returns and congressman Brady
said that he wasn't going to recommend
this because it would violate Donald
Trump's privacy but when you're
President of the United States
you really have to give up a lot of
privacy because you're a public servant
and not just any public servant but you
represent so much of what America is and
in the will of all of the people and
that's kind of why the Secret Service
doesn't just allow you to go anywhere
and yes you have to face all these
different restrictions and it should be
one of Donald Trump's let the American
people into some of those discussions at
mar-a-lago
about the North Korean missile launch
deciding to hold those discussions as
well as would the Japanese Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe a in front of people
just hanging out on the patio so in that
way Donald Trump has given up his
privacy has me why did Republicans do
this probably for a number of reasons
number one they might be afraid of what
they'll find in the tax returns and then
they'll be pressured to actually take
action against Trump as a result of it
or those Republicans are running for
re-election next year and they don't
want to alienate trump supporters or
Donald Trump himself and they also
probably want Donald Trump's to sign the
bills that they put forward the what's
the future of this I don't know
yesterday the House Judiciary Committee
voted on a resolution to demand the
Justice Department give them documents
that would maybe shed some light on
Trump's conflicts of interest and ties
with Russia the committee voted that
down as well I don't know that we're
ever going to see those tax returns yeah
probably not there's a long ways to go
because this foot was completely on
party lines and you need to sway 45
Republicans yeah over and then even then
you have to get a recommendation from
the Treasury Department
Steve minuchin is of course the Donald
Trump appoint D yeah you have to get the
Ways and Means Committee which is
controlled by Republicans to release it
to the rest of Congress I mean there's a
lot of steps there maybe the hacking
possibility is the most likely to
actually reveal Trump's tax returns yeah
I mean hacking a president I'm sure
that's obviously illegal yeah but you
know it's out of the interest of the
American public your suspicion is right
it may be illegal to hack the tax
returns of a president Gamefly is sort
of like Netflix for video games they
have over 8,000 new and classic games
for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you would return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent game
through the mobile app yet the free
30-day trial for the David Pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s